i would like to personally thank imovie
for that fantastic trailer that made my
adventures on this cruise look so much
cooler i made a playlist of all of the
videos that i made here you can click
this link here or click the link in the
description and if you've never actually
used a playlist before hold on let me
show you how it works yeah click on it
and then all these little videos show up
in the bottom and you can just pick the
ones that you want to watch not if any
of you guys have ever really been on a
cruise before or been on a boat for a
long period of time but after we got off
this boat we still felt like we were on
this boat for a good four days after
that is not a good feeling because when
you're sitting on the toilet and you
think that you're on a boat you're not
on a boat or you're sitting at your
computer or you're standing up and
walking to the refrigerator and you
think you're on a boat you're not anyway
be sure to check out all of my videos
from my cruise playlist here let me know
which one is your favorite and let me
know if you guys have ever been on a
cruise tell me some of your crazy
vacation experiences i'm sure you've got
them not only were we stuck on this boat
for seven days which was a very fun
seven days but this was when hurricane
sandy was cruising through and we had to
follow the storm back to florida and
this boat was moving like you would not
believe like i thought it was going to
fall off of the ship from my bed outside
into the water thankfully we made it
back safely and if any of you guys have
been affected by hurricane sandy i hope
that you guys are recovering i hope that
you are all okay and i hope that your
friends and family are safe and i love
you all